(audience cheering)
- It's nice to meet you.
- [Austin] Nice to meet you.
- You are incredibly talented.
- Oh, thank you.
- This film, people are gonna freak out.
I'm just saying, you're incredibly gifted.
So you're playing such an icon, Elvis.
Were you musical as a kid?
- My dad gave me a guitar
when I was 13 years old
and I obsessed about it.
I would play for eight hours a day.
My fingers would bleed and
I'd Super Glue 'em shut
and keep playing, but I
never played for anybody.
It was like therapy.
- You were shy about it?
- [Austin] So shy.
- Oh my gosh, you were shy and
you ended up playing Elvis?
That's ironic.
(audience laughing)
Did you play anything else?
- Yeah, I played the piano as well.
I picked that up about
a year after the guitar.
And that opened up, you learn a lot
about music playing the piano.
It opened up a lot.
- I love that.
And it's like, even if you
didn't become a musician
in a band, it's an amazing
thing, I think, even my kids
I'm like, "You don't have to be in a band,
but I want you to play something."
I think it's good for you.
I think it's therapeutic.
- Do they play instruments?
- My daughter plays violin a little bit.
My son is six. He hasn't started yet.
- Violin was the first
thing I learned how to play.
- Me too. It was violin and then piano.
- Were you shy as a kid?
- Yes, until music. Interesting.
- That broke you out.
Yeah, nobody believes me.
(audience laughing)
But I was shy at some point in my life.
My mom will tell you.
And I was very, I don't
know, just introverted,
and then music brought me to life,
my personality and everything.
I think anytime when you're a kid,
I don't know if you agree,
you find that one thing
that really helps you flourish
and find your personality
and find out who you are.
- That was acting for me.
- But you started acting
in a weird way, right?
Was it your brother?
(Austin laughing)
- Yeah, I had a stepbrother
and he got scouted
at the Orange County Fair.
And we all thought, "Oh,
he's gonna be a movie star.
He's gonna go off and
do all these things."
And so I just tagged along as he went up
to this audition in Los Angeles.
And when they saw that
my mom had another kid
they were like, "Does he wanna do it too?"
My mom said, "Are you interested?"
I don't know what came over me that day,
'cause I was so shy, but I said "yeah"
and then it turned out it was
a background talent agent.
So it got you into doing extra work
on Nickelodeon shows and stuff.
And that's what got me into it.
- That's the door.
Everybody needs the door.
- When I got my first manager
and started going to acting class,
and acting class broke me
out of my shyness, in a way.
That gave me an outlet for it.
- Did they make you just
do the most awkward things?
- Yeah, always.
- Okay. I've never done it.
I wanna do it just for fun,
just to force myself to
hate my life a little bit.
(Austin and audience laughing)
You're supposed to do
things that you don't think
you'd be good at to grow or whatever.
It feels like it would terrify me.
(audience cheering)
That was the look at him as
Elvis in the new movie "Elvis".
The movie is amazing.
So can you explain to
everybody how you got the role?
- I sent Baz a tape.
I heard that he was making
the film and I sent him a tape
of me singing "Unchained
Melody" and playing the piano.
- God, I love that song, classic.
- Such a beautiful song.
And he responded to it and
then I flew to New York
and we met and we just
talked for three hours.
And then he said, "You
wanna come in tomorrow
and read a couple scenes from the script?"
And so I came in and read a
couple scenes and then he said,
"Do you wanna come in tomorrow
and sing a couple songs?
And you wanna sing 'Suspicious Minds'?"
And so I went home that night
and practiced and I come back
we ended up doing that for five months.
- What?
- It was unlike any audition,
where it was just five
months of exploring.
- That's a relationship.
(audience laughing)
- And then it came time
for the screen test,
- [Kelly] Then it came time for the, okay.
- There comes a point where
the studio has to sign off.
And you gotta do the screen test.
And so I'd prepared everything
and got to the screen test
and Baz changed everything
on me on the day.
I was supposed to do
a couple scenes and he
changed the scenes and changed
all the words in the scenes.
And then I was supposed
to sing three songs.
And then he starts describing
the scene to me and he saying,
"You're gonna sing these three songs."
And they weren't the
songs that I'd prepared.
And so suddenly I'm on set and I go,
"Baz, I don't think I have the
material that you gave me."
And he goes, "Oh no, we changed it,
but I'll get you new material."
And then turns out he
never got me new material
and he starts filming while
I'm learning everything.
So then I start going through it
and then he cut one of
the scenes and he said,
"Now we're gonna do you
performing 'Suspicious Minds'."
- Is he just messing
with you at this point?
(audience laughing)
I would look around for
Ashton Kutcher at this point.
(Austin laughing)
Am I being punked?
That's horrible.
- He put me through the wringer.
And I realize now he likes to
be very spontaneous on set.
He wanted to see if I would lose my mind.
And so I didn't think I got it.
And then a week later I got a call
and I woke up to Baz calling me.
And I thought, "Okay this is the moment,
I either have it or I don't."
And he's very dramatic in the
way that he goes about things.
He sounded downcast. He goes--
- [Kelly] Oh, how mean. (laughs)
- "I just wanted to be the
first one to call you and say,
are you ready to fly, Mr. Presley?"
It's just the greatest
phone call I've ever had.
(audience applauding)
- I love that.
But that's a lot of
emotional roller coaster,
up and down to get there.
Do you think that it
might have been because,
I heard Denzel called him because
y'all had worked together,
and was trying to help you get the role
'cause he loved you and believed in you.
Do you think it's something
he said that was like,
"Nah, Imma see how much he
really will work"? (laughs)
- I don't know if that played
into it. It's possible.
- I don't know that anyone
has that in this business.
Oh, Denzel called Baz.
Did he know Baz?
- [Austin] No, they never met before.
- Denzel Washington calls you.
I know, look at your teary eyes.
- He's powerful. He's
been my hero for so long.
I went into that play going,
"I'm not gonna try to be Denzel's friend."
I'd read Ethan Hawke talking about them
doing "Training Day" together
and he talked about this as well.
And so I went in there and I thought,
"I'm just gonna do my job."
And so I showed up the
first day of rehearsal
I'd memorized a four hour
play, such an intense play.
And we did it and at a certain point
Denzel started seeing
that I was showing up
earlier than he was to get to the theater.
And so he'd show up a little bit earlier.
(Kelly laughing)
And then I'd show up a little bit earlier.
Eventually one day it was
just he and I and he thought
that he was there before
me and I came down,
I'd already been up in my dressing room.
And it is just the dark theater
and he's sitting on the stage by himself
and I came walking down, he goes,
"I thought I'd beat you here."
And I said, "No, I've
been here for an hour."
(Kelly laughing)
- But nice try.
- He goes, "I got an idea for you."
And he took me under his wing
and started giving me acting advice.
And that was really huge for me.
He didn't tell me he was
gonna call Baz at all.
He'd never met Baz.
- That's so nice.
- Very sweet.
- I love that you made
such an impact on him
that he did something like that.
- Very kind.
- That's very, very cool.
You did get to meet Priscilla Presley.
What was that like? Was it intimidating?
- Super intimidating. But she
didn't make it intimidating.
I met her the same day
I went to Graceland for the first time.
- I've never been.
- [Austin] You've never been?
- No. And I lived in Tennessee for years.
I just don't know, work.
- It's amazing. It's so great.
Baz and I took this road trip
right after I got the part
where we went and recorded in Nashville.
It was the first recording
studio I was ever in.
- It's a great place to record.
- Studio B there. Where Dolly
Parton recorded "Jolene."
Elvis recorded over 270 songs, I believe.
So we took this road trip
and ended up in Graceland.
And next door, there's this
hotel where I met Priscilla.
And she was just so, so beautiful
and so warm and welcoming.
And she just gave me a big hug and said,
"You have a lot of support."
I walked outta that hotel room
just with tears in my eyes.
It's amazing when you look into her eyes
and you think, "This is the same woman
that Elvis was madly in love with.
She was madly in love with him.
She's the mother of his only child.
And then she's right here in front of me."
It's really surreal.
We got to go to the Met Gallery recently
and we danced a bit
and, and she's the best.
She's incredible.
- I love that.
You seem very present.
Are you always that present
and thinking like that in life?
Just being in the moment like that?
Not many people are like that.
- I try to be. It's hard
with what we do sometimes.
- I'm working at it and I just
turned 40, Austin. (laughs)
- Well, you look amazing.
- Well, thank you for lying. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
But thank you so much, Austin.
Everybody, we need another break.
Go see "Elvis," it's in theaters tomorrow.
You won't regret it.
(audience cheering)